[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday June
21st do 21st that's the longest day of
the year the summer solstice and to
celebrate I was gonna take you guys
outside on the town of Azula to enjoy
the longest day of the year but I forgot
to charge my battery so I am stuck to
the house with the wires I didn't get
you a little change of scenery this is
the upstairs of my house I do really
love the amazing summer days of Missoula
the average length for a day on planet
Earth is 12 hours we've defined it that
way but the further away from the
equator you get the bigger the extremes
get and we're pretty far away from the
equator here so right now instead of 12
hours a day is like 15 16 hours long
it doesn't technically matter because I
spend 80% of my waking hours in a
basement I don't mean I can't appreciate
it and then I don't like going outside
and feeling the warmth of the Sun on my
skin I gotta get outside I did I forget
to charge my camera battery oh I have an
idea
[Music]
I'm outside hey my cats coming to look
at me um do you actually make this a
little bit difficult cameo this is my
side yard I've always wanted to plant a
vegetable garden here but since they
don't actually own my house I can't get
permission to do it
Wow the probably looks pretty horrible
and I have sworn to myself that when I
get my own house I will not have grass
I will only have vegetables carrots
growing like weeds and beds of lettuce
everywhere and tomato plants up the butt
oh oh and you know some flowers and
stuff too but mostly I want edible stuff
it's like actually productive instead of
grass which is just seems really
ridiculous to me Bluffs vegetables are
often very very pretty plants so you
asked me what I think you should do with
all that grass turn it out of the
drought and then put down raised beds
all over the place and then you water
those but that's okay because vegetables
have to be watered anyways so it's
either they get watered at the farm or
they get watered at your house it's the
same amount of water for the same amount
of vegetable plus you save money and
have something really cool to look after
that's not a pet or a child which is
good because unlike pets or kids you can
neglect it and no one will arrest you
though the Neighborhood Association
might give you a fine so that is my
suggestion I very strongly suggest that
you don't keep the grass because in
Australia they only have sixty two weeks
of water left and really it should be
used for agriculture because we need to
eat we don't need green lawns but that's
just my opinion maybe somebody needs
green lawns but it's not the green
brothers we don't need green lawns we
need green vegetables so we can grow up
strong a big and also not quite as big
as most of America so this is my outdoor
version of Brotherhood 2.0 coming into
an internet cafe in Indianapolis near
you John I will see you tomorrow